[Music]
this symbol of a red ribbon is often
seen by us at many places but what does
this signify it's a symbol used to
create awareness about acquired
immunodeficiency syndrome abbreviated as
AIDS or simply human immunodeficiency
virus abbreviated as HIV the concept of
red ribbon was adopted to create
awareness for the disease as well as to
morally uplift the people suffering from
it now before moving ahead with the
disease let's first learn what do we
mean by a syndrome it's a condition
identified by a set of related symptoms
in simple words AIDS or any syndrome is
a collection of symptoms that develop
together like in the case of AIDS since
the case leads to multiple infections
due to the weakening of the immune
system the person suffering shows
multiple symptoms all at the same time
so hypothetically if the person
contracts TB typhoid and cholera then
symptoms of all three will be
collectively seen in the patient this is
why AIDS is called a syndrome in this
video let's learn about this syndrome
which is an infectious disease in detail
HIV is an infectious retrovirus and what
do we mean by a retrovirus we know that
there are different types of viruses
classified mainly on the basis of their
genetic material
among the various types those viruses
which have RNA as the genetic material
are called retroviruses these viruses
insert their genetic material into the
host cell to cause an infection and post
infection the major task of this virus
is to attack the immune system of the
host and weaken it this strategy is used
by the HIV to conquer over the hosts
body completely now let's move ahead and
learn a bit more about AIDS
this disease develops in the HIV
infected people if their immune system
is severely compromised the people
suffering from AIDS are highly
susceptible to any disease as their
immune system loses the capacity to
fight off even acute infections
efficiently now how does this virus
enter a healthy host the HIV has the
tendency to stay active and spread only
through body fluids so it gets access to
a healthy hosts body only through some
form of body fluid these can include
blood semen placental transmission and
many other ways we have often heard the
saying
prevention is better than cure this is
very much apt in the case of AIDS as
there's no cure once the disease reaches
a particular stage the only thing that
can be done is prevention and how is
that achieved since ages the most
frequent mode of transmission is through
sexual contact does avoiding unprotected
sexual intercourse is the best way to
prevent transmission of HIV the other
frequent method of transmission includes
blood transfusion
so getting blood transfused without
prior examination should strictly be
avoided
also the spread of HIV through blood
becomes possible with the use of
syringes or the equipment's which are
already used thus reusing syringes for
medications or even sharp instruments
like razors for personal use should be
avoided and lastly HIV easily passes
from a mother to her child during
pregnancy or delivery or through
breastfeeding does proper medications
and measures that will prevent the
transmission of HIV to the child should
be carried out these are a few methods
in which transmission of HIV infection
can be prevented and how is one detected
with the infection if the unfortunate
event does strike the diagnostic
technique used for testing the presence
of HIV is called enzyme-linked
immunosorbent
sorbent assay abbreviated as Eliza we
note that the HIV is not really curable
after a certain point so what can be
done in case a person gets infected
there are different drugs available
today that can be consumed to control
the viral growth due to technological
advancement now we do have few therapies
known as the antiretroviral therapies
which can be performed on the victims of
HIV infection all these medications and
therapies make sure that the person's
body does not support or help in
extremely rapid propagation of HIV
population within it with this we come
to an end of our discussion on the topic
of AIDS and HIV do subscribe to our
channel for more interesting facts and
concepts happy learning
[Music]
you